it's been a year since I've put out this
changing World Order which showed these
long-term cycles and the short-term
cycles and pretty much things have
transpired along that Arc in other words
three big things
the creation of a lot of debt and front
printing of money which is produced an
inflation acceleration which has raised
the tightness of monetary policy and
affected markets second the internal
conflicts between the left and the right
and the political developments and that
has to do with social impacts and all of
that arguing and that Division and we're
seeing it reflected in the politics
and third
the great power conflicts so we've seen
the war with Russia developed and then
we've seen also of course the tensions
and the approaching of a greater
conflict with China as there is a
struggle for the power of the world and
the changing world order so that power
that Ark is
um continuing in the broad sense and so
we're at the Brinks of these things and
as we watch them you know some things
um maybe are a little bit better some
things are a little bit worse you know
when I described it I said there's a 30
chance
of some type of internal Civil War you
know 30 chance meaning that there's a
conflict that maybe you don't follow the
rules
30 chance I'd say there's a 35 chance
now roughly speaking that doesn't mean
it's likely but you can see that we're
on the brink of that you can also see
that in terms of the internal conflict
reflected in a number of things that we
are right at the brink and the same is
true for the international Wars we're
right at the brink that doesn't mean
that we're going over the brink but it
means that those things are driving
everything they're driving how the
economy is working they're driving how
the markets are working they're driving
how inflation is taking place they're
driving out the world is evolving in
terms of its various parts and the
internal conflicts so by and large we're
watching these episodes take place as
this is transpiring